good morning Hank it's Monday first act
correct something about your video from
Friday you said the project for awesome
begins at midnight on December 17th in
fact it begins at noon Eastern Time
December 17th so upload your videos as
close to noon as possible and then tune
in to youtube.com slash P for a sewing
today I want to tell you about eight
things I love thing one this book Anna
and the French kiss by Stephanie Perkins
holy mood do I love this book so a
couple years ago at LeakyCon a
nerdfighter comes up to me and she says
I'm a nerdfighter and I wrote a book
it's coming out in 2010 can I send you a
copy and I said sure right so
flash-forward two years I get this book
in the mail and I'm like I'll read a
page or two and then I can't stop
reading it because it is made of
sweetness and funny and awesome
hey and the French kiss is like Maureen
Johnson and I had a baby a French baby
no it is nothing like that but it is
super funny and smart and one of the
most genuinely romantic stories I have
ever read second thing I love karen
kavett who designed that karen has been
a nerdfighter forever she's on the
project for awesome thumbnail this year
she did all the French Revolution videos
and I'm just so grateful for her thing
three beckoning lovely Hank as you know
I'm obsessed with my friend Amy Krauss
Rosenthal's beckoning of lovely project
in which he tries to beckon lovely
things into the world you can find a
link to a video of what happened on
10-10-10 in chicago in the doobly-doo
and it might make you cry it makes me
cry ah but I'm crier Hank I don't think
you've ever cried in any of our videos
up to see you crying a video I can't I
don't think I've seen you cry since you
were a kid probably the last time I saw
you cry was when I was bunching you
thing for this shirt which is currently
stuck on my glasses and which was given
to me by nerimon thanks al extinct 5
Charlie so like I met Charlie McDonald
when he was to use the language of his
native country but a young lad but even
back then I remember thinking this kid
aside from being outrageously handsome
is cottagey Gnaeus ever since Charlie
has been proving me right but never more
than on his new album this is me which
is I honestly I've not been able to stop
listening to it on iTunes it's the only
thing in my iTunes I have bread on
repeat and I've listened to it 621 times
this raises the alarming possibility
that I might technically be a fangirl
also on the back of his CD he
wrote I hope you like it and then
hopeful jar Li I like the Charlie thing
six white dog white snow things seven
Hank I have perhaps saved the best for
nearly last so a couple weeks ago my
friend Joe Felice asked me to
participate in the station is watching
you a show that works to give new
youtubers a bigger audience
Joe chose for me a user named of I heart
and French the llama is she amazing the
crazy part of the story is that vihart
has been a nerdfighter since 2007 and in
fact designed the original nerdfighter
pirate logo nerdfighters click here
watch a vibe video and your whole life
will be changed you may think you hate
math but you don't hate math you hate
the way you've been taught math Hank's
you can also play jingle bells with
candy buttons which is a major
development in the history of candy
buttons and lastly Hank thing ate the
Napoleon so Hank this is Napoleon and
lately my son Henry has taken to
pointing in the direction he would like
to be taken Hank I love the Napoleon
because Henry clearly believes that I am
a horse
he's like and now we shall head that way
horse to the candy so I got stuff I love
nerdfighters writing books and making
music and making videos about
mathemusician ship nerdfighters please
tell me some stuff that you love so I
can find new stuff to love and Hank
don't forget to be awesome this is the
end screen where we do the end screen
stuff there's vihart and charlie karen
kavett the beckoning of lovely there is
a link to get Anna and the French kiss
by nerdfighter Stephanie Perkins in the
doobly-doo also don't forget to
subscribe to youtube.com slash p4a where
the magic will begin Friday at noon
eastern